[Music]
it's all about vogue
kendall Jenner Gigi Hadid and Ashley
Graham son on the fashion Bibles March
cover posing alongside what the mag is
calling the next wave of models the
cover comes along with another milestone
for Gigi she's now a Barbie doll the
March issue also gifted us with a new 73
questions this time featuring Lena
Dunham
all right you have 9 tattoos can you
quickly give the story behind every
tattoo yes this is Verdun in the bowl
he's a famous pacifist then on my side
Jemima tattooed a little picture of her
dog Rosie over on this side I have an
illustration from a children's book a
drunk I did it it's not great I should
get it covered up then I have Laura
Thornhill who's one of the first female
skateboarders in history then on my butt
I have a snake wrapped around the moon
and I also have the sign for the Odeon
my favorite restaurant and Tribeca
if l-louise does a [ __ ] stamp you know
Eloise who lived at the Plaza and then
it says staunch right there for Grey
Gardens okay and what's that - number 10
gonna be I'm sure mine was playing -
taught you the word nasty on my butt
you